23 parce qu'il a péché par insuffisance
de centrisme françois fillon juppé
n'aurait pas subi la défaite cinglante
qui la subit la primaire ce que je
rappelle que les militants les
républicains n'étaient pas les seuls à
voter pouvaient voter l'aide à ils ont
d'endroits où il chante des socialistes
rappelez vous il y avait eu des
socialistes qui sont venus apporter on
sait maintenant la suave est un sondage
leur voix à alain juppé qui parle c'est
en fait patrick stefanini qui est
d'abord à juppéiste déçu un amoureux
éconduit il a attendu longtemps qu'elle
a juppé lui fasse signe en lui disant
s'il te plaît sauvant directeur de
campagne et c'est par dépit
parce qu'elle a juppé ne l'a pas appelé
que fillon les ja en ayant contacté il a
accepté de mener la campagne de fillon
bon alors déjà on part sur cette base là
en plus
l'étroitesse des scores de l'ordre
d'arrivée le pen fille en mélenchon est
tel que bien malin qui peut deviner la
part des affaires où la part du
programme dans le fait que fillon soit
arrivé troisième ça c'est vraiment de la
lecture dans le marc de café
et enfin comme le disait péricaud fillon
le programme de fillon a rencontré une
adhésion très large non seulement de la
base des républicains mais dans le pays
beaucoup de points de son programme
était plébiscité et d'ailleurs macron
les reprend peu ou prou qu'ils avaient
la trouille qui ne voulait pas de ce
programme les chapeaux à plumes des
républicains qui dès que fillon a été
hors jeu pour les législatives se sont
empressés de raboter son programme
sordide un poids plume alain juppé
françois baroin tout ce qui reste c'est
nicolas sarkozy compris dans raboter la
cohérence je rappelle par exemple que
françois fillon voulait supprimer les 35
heures
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont remis
la défiscalisation des heures sup que
préconisait sarkozy ce qui ne tient pas
debout où on se débarrasse des trois
accords on s'en débarrasse pas mais on
ne parle pas des heures sup